want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jordan peterson
enjoy
you really are your only comparison
group especially as you get older
because your life is so idiosyncratic
and peculiar that
any compare i mean look you have to care
what other people think it's stupid to
think otherwise be
because you have to be social and you
have to be aware of what other people
are doing and all of that so
it's this is a psychopathic individual
individuality but it is genuinely true
that no one has your set of
opportunities and limitations
and so the the comparison just isn't
real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional you know because maybe
you see someone who's re i've dealt with
i've i've met many people who are very
very rich
and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and material
plenty but
j and they're shielded from
many catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder but
their lives are still full of exactly
the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see well the
person's worked 80 hours a week for 40
years and it's blown all his
relationships out of the water it's like
yes he's rich but he's also old now
you know he's 60. and one of the best
predictors of wealth is age you know
really do you want to be young and poor
or old and rich it's like i'd pick young
and poor
because you can't buy youth
and so and that's something that's worth
considering but you don't know what
burdens the people you're jealous of are
carrying
so
leave it be
it's not it's not helpful to you to to
to be envious if you know what you want
then you know when you're failing
if you don't allow yourself to know what
you want you can keep that foggy
um if you don't set out the conditions
for your success then you can avoid your
responsibility because again that's not
clear and the problem with wanting
something is that in all probability
you're going to have to work for it
you're going to have to make sacrifices
and it's certainly possible that you
want to avoid that
you you you might be afraid to make it
clear because other people could deny it
to you too which is something i write
about a fair bit in that chapter
the problem is and
and
failing to make any of that clear
protects you right now
but it's really hard on you over the
medium to long term
because if you don't make it clear to
yourself what you want or to other
people the probability that you're just
going to stumble into it is pretty low
and and you can put that off
indefinitely day after day but the
problem with that is that you age while
you're doing that and
there's a obviously a price to be paid
for that
so
that chapter that's chapter three do not
hide things in the fog
[Music]
i mean it's a it's a warning about
failing to pay attention
you know
knowledge emerges in a very strange way
it it emerges
obviously when we learn something we
started out by not knowing it and so
what that means is that knowledge goes
through a transformation process
from being absolutely not there to being
explicit and fully detailed
and one step of that process is emotion
and so for example you might find
yourself frustrated disappointed about
the events of the day but be unable to
exactly specify why that's extremely
common you know you go home to your
partner and you be in a bad mood and you
know you'll snap at them for something
and they'll say well what's up with you
and you'll say well nothing you're just
being annoying when it's perfectly clear
to both of you that there is actually
something up with you
and then that disappointment and
frustration anger and sadness let's say
or anxiety is a sign that something
isn't right but it isn't like it isn't
necessarily that you're repressing
knowledge of what's not right it's that
you just you actually don't know
and the emotion is the first step in the
process by which that knowledge emerges
and you might have to sit and think and
talk to your partner or to a friend for
god only knows how long before you're
actually going to put your finger on
what it is that you're upset about
and it could be
very far removed from whatever happened
to trigger you in the moment
and so
that's the fog and you can keep things
in the fog just by not doing that it's
really easy it's no dif more difficult
than just sitting there doing nothing
because creating knowledge is active and
difficult we're built to walk uphill
and
when you
reach the pinnacle of the hill you want
to stop and appreciate the vision but
the next thing you want is a higher hill
in the distance because
it's the uphill climb that
it's it's from the uphill climb that we
derive our value and i mean this
technically so almost all the positive
emotion we feel especially the the
the emotion that fills us with
enthusiasm and that's to be filled with
the spirit of god by the way because
that's what enthusiasm means
that's
experienced in relationship to a goal
and so in some sense and this is part of
the religious enterprise you want a goal
that you can never attain right so you
can always move closer to the goal that
recedes as you move towards it you think
well that's frustrating it's like
sisyphus pushing the rock uphill but
it's not because as you pursue that goal
you put yourself together and your life
does get better and richer and more
abundant and that's why the highest
levels of virtue and goal are in some
sense transcendent
you want them to be above everything
you're doing so you can continually move
towards something that's more sublime
and better
that's what you are you're here to live
not to
not to sleep
and the problem with the vision of my
ties on the beach is that well first of
all that's an envision that's a vision
of of drug-induced unconsciousness
second it's only going to work for about
a week third you're going to be a
laughingstock in a month and depressed
and aimless
and and goalless it's no that's not it's
it's you want a horizon of ever
expanding possibility and so it does
happen to people as they because they've
staked their soul
on the attainment of an instrumental
goal and it can be a pretty high order
goal it was in your case but then you
think
well i've now i'm there now what
well the answer can't be
well i'm going to live in the lap of
luxury and never have to leave the fa
what do you want to be a giant infant
with a gold with a gold bottle you never
have to do anything but lay in your back
and suck it's like
well you see the problem with that as a
as a
as a conceptualization it's no you want
to be
like an active warrior moving up hill
with your sword in hand and
that's that's dynamic that's exciting
and that's why so many young men
disappear into video games it's that's
all acted out in the video game
so they have to act that out in their
own life not that i despise video games
because i don't but they're not a
substitute for life
they might be good training under some
conditions for life you go to a party
your heart's beating why the party is a
monster why because it's judging you and
it's judging you it's putting you low
down the dominance hierarchy because
that's what a negative judgment is and
that interferes with your sexual
success and that means that you're being
harshly evaluated by nature itself
right so you are confronting that the
dragon of chaos when you go into the
social situation and so what do you do
you're like this right you hunch over
and that's low dominance i'm no threat
it's like well that's not going to get
you very far you know but that's a
logical thing to do in in the in the
face of a tyrant so i'm no threat you
know you look at the king and you're
dead i'm no threat i'm hunched over
and then what's happening internally how
what are people thinking about me what
are people thinking about me am i
looking stupid am i looking foolish geez
i'm awkward i hate being here man i'm
sweating too much it's all internalized
right it's all self-focused the the the
eye isn't work the eye isn't working
what do you tell people
stop don't stop thinking about yourself
because you can't it's like don't think
of a white elephant white elephant white
elephant white elephant you can't tell
someone to stop thinking about something
because they get caught in a loop what
you do with socially anxious people is
you say
look at other people
look at them
right why because if you look at them
you can tell what they're thinking
and then you you're unless you're unless
you're terribly socialized and some
people are some people have no social
skills and so the reason they can't go
to a party is because they don't even
know how to introduce themselves like
they're just no one ever taught them how
to behave and so they're really good
candidates for behavior therapy because
you walk them through the process of how
you actually manifest the procedures
that are associated with social
acceptability but most people aren't
like that they have the ability so if
they're really introverted and high in
neuroticism they can usually talk quite
well to someone one-on-one why because
they look at them
well if i look at you it's another thing
to do if you're ever speaking to a group
of people never speak to the group of
people that doesn't exist you talk to
individuals and then they reflect for
you the entire group because they're all
entrained so you look at one person
they broadcast to you what everyone's
thinking and you know how to talk to one
person so it's easy
so as soon as you focus on the person
not you you push your attention outward
use your eye you push your attention
outward and you start watching well then
all your automatic mechanisms kick in
and you stop being awkward because if
we're talking and i'm looking here
i don't know what you're going to do
next and i'm going to put disjunctions
into the like they're like
bad chords in the melody of our of our
conversation and the reason is i'm not
paying attention
so that's why the eye is the thing at
the top of the pyramid it's like the
thing that enables you to win the set of
all possible dominance harkies is the
eye pay attention pay attention that's
the critical issue that's why the
egyptians worshiped horus that's why
horus was the thing that rescued osiris
from the from the depths it's the
capacity to pay attention what do you
pay attention to most
what your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous it attracts your attention
it's like this isn't going quite right
i'm not looking at that
wrong
that's what you look at that's what you
look at what's not going right because
that's see that's the terrible monster
that might eat you but it's also the
place you get all the information
so
that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies
because they will tell you things you do
not know and that's such a great thing
because if you don't know them well
you're not very smart are you you know
there may be a time when you go
somewhere that's the thing you need to
know
and maybe your enemy will tell you why
you're such a fool you know and a bunch
of other things that aren't true too
but even one thing that's accurate it's
like yeah thanks very much man maybe
i'll do some work on that and i won't
have to carry that forward
so and then that's part of the reason
again why the terrible predator it's
always the terrible predator that has
the gold it's like it's the person who
delivers the message you do not want to
hear
so it's rough it's rough but it doesn't
matter
life is rough responsibility
that's what gives life meaning
it's like lift a load
then you can tolerate yourself right
because look at you're useless
easily hurt easily killed why should you
have any self-respect that's the story
of the fall
pick something up and carry it pic make
it heavy enough so that you can think
yeah well useless as i am at least i
could move that from there to there well
what's really cool about that is that
when i talk to these crowds about this
the man's eyes light up
and that's very like i've seen that
phenomenon because i've been talking
about this mythological material for a
long time and i can see when i'm
watching crowds people you know their
eyebrows lift their eyes light up
because i put something together for
them that's what mythological stories do
so i'm not taking responsibility for
that that's what the stories do so i say
the story people go click click click
you know when their eyes light up but
this responsibility thing that's a whole
new order of this is that young men are
so hungry for that it is unbelievable
and one of the things i've been talking
to some of the people who've been
um running for the conservative
leadership in canada and i've been
talking to them about well the
difficulties they have communicating
with young people because conservatives
what the hell are they going to sell to
young people right because being
conservative is something that happens
when you're older they can sell
responsibility you're going to use what
you think to guide your action and the
consequence of that is going to be how
your life turns out
so i'm dead serious about what i write
because
because i know what the pathway is it's
like you don't you don't communicate in
a false manner because if you do you
will warp the structure that guides your
actions and you will absolutely
absolutely 100 percent suffer for that i
mean one of the things i've learned as a
clinical psychologist
is that i've never seen anyone it's
really a terrifying thing i've never
seen anyone get away with anything ever
it the chickens always come home to
roost so and sometimes it might you know
let's say you get away with something
it's like yeah you think so man
you wait five years from now seven years
from now it'll come back is that karma
it's more like yes i think it's the same
idea but it's more like
you you can't
you you you don't have the power to
manipulate reality
like you have the power to bring about
reality in some sense because you
confront potential and through your
actions and and and your communicative
intent you turn potential into reality
but you don't have the you don't have
the power to bend reality without it
snapping you don't think so
you don't think so so you don't think
visionaries and influencers have the
ability to bend reality no i don't think
they bend it i think that they they
they i mean you can bring new things
into being
but you can't you can't get away with a
falsehood
oh you can definitely bring new things
into being you can't get away with a
false yes that's it
okay makes sense and and you can't get
away with weak thinking either
because
i mean any more than you can get away
with improper action it just doesn't
work
so you're you're contending it's what's
why i mean one of the themes in my
writing is the danger of falsehood
and at any at every level it's like well
if you tell the truth to the degree that
you can or at least don't lie that think
that's rule eight
um then you have reality on your side
you gotta decide and you want reality on
your side or do you want reality against
you
i wouldn't recommend the whole reality
against you thing because you're not
going to win you're going to get
flattened
and so i'm very careful with what i say
and i'm very careful with what i write
we are thrown
challenges and that they're
that and that in some sense those are
best construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what jung thought his idea
was something like this that at the
beginning of time people were
unconscious
and that consciousness emerged with all
of its catastrophes consciousness of
death for example and
one way out of the burden of
consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness you can do that with
alcohol you can do that by being
dependent you can do that by failing to
grow up you refuse the burden of
consciousness by
becoming unconscious again but there's
another way forward which is to become
even more conscious so the idea would be
a little bit of consciousness is like an
illness but if you can expand that
consciousness upwards enough then it's
time something it starts to become
something that it's all that is its own
cure and that partly what your goal is
while you suffer through life is to
heighten your consciousness to the point
where everything gets integrated enough
so that that's proper medication for the
disease of self-consciousness because
it's one thing to live properly and
that's not a trivial thing but it's
another thing to be able to articulate
yourself and to be able to negotiate and
generally speaking there's nothing about
that that isn't advantageous and even
introverted and anxious people can learn
to do that you know it's those are
learnable skills it's not easy but but
but you can manage it
you can also
you can also speak carefully you know
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true that's also unbelievably useful
you have to feel that out like is this
really what i believe or am i putting it
forward well because i want to look good
or i want to dominate or
uh
or i want to express
obliquely an emotion that i'm too
cowardly to come out and confront
directly or am i being manipulative
there's lots of reasons that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is to state what you believe to
be true and then to let the consequences
of that unfold
and so that can also
help you
simple truths
bluntly stated can be very powerful you
don't need a lot of verbal fluency under
those circumstances
if there's evidence of strength of
character behind it well the best advice
that you can really give to people who
are young is that unless you have very
good reason not to you should do what
all people have always done
and so what does that mean i i when i
see my clinical clients although i'm not
practicing anymore when i saw my
clinical clients i would evaluate their
lives across a number of dimensions
um
did would were they immersed in the
network of friendships
did they have a family and that could be
their family of birth but also
the family that they've produced their
own husband or wife and children
if they were of an age where that was
appropriate
did they have a career or at least a job
and was their job productive and
um matched well with their abilities and
their ambitions were they educated to
the extent that their intelligence and
curiosity might demand
were they in reasonable physical and
mental health
independent of those other areas
all of those things need to be
established and
you don't want to question them so much
that you don't establish them you might
think of yourself as a rebel and someone
who's particularly unique and it's also
it's also possible that you are unique
in one or more ways but
but
fundamentally speaking
if you don't do what everyone else does
then
the probability that you're abdicating
your responsibility and that you will
miss out on something important is
extremely high
so
you know our culture
virtually every movie that's made for
children now you see this coming out of
the disney studios constantly always
concentrates on the special child who's
got abilities that no other child has
and is being crushed by society into
being
you know unpleasantly normal and
and and
there is a fair bit of crushing that
goes along with being socialized because
part of being socialized is to become
like everyone else but you don't want to
um
underestimate the benefit of that it's
it's very very difficult to tread your
own path and you're only going to be
able to do that in a limited number of
areas
you blow apart the social routines
you'll find yourself out there in
a domain of chaos that will overwhelm
you and that's not pleasant and then
with regards to your goals
let's say you don't know what to do well
maybe you're high in openness and so
you're pulled in all sorts of directions
or maybe you're low in conscientiousness
or you're confused because you're
anxious or you haven't had any direction
you haven't had good mentoring etc etc
there's lots of reasons well i would say
pick something
right pick something
a nameable goal
and then try to implement it and what'll
happen is
you'll learn a lot by trying to
implement it and one of the things you
might learn is
what the
a slightly better goal might be
you know because if you try something
diligently
and you succeed or you fail
um you're going to learn from the
the effort expanded in the detailed
implementation of the goal it's going to
inform you it'll also transform you
physiologically it does that at a very
basic level neural neurophysiological
level
you will be slightly different as a
consequence of the attempt and what that
will mean is that the next goal you pick
will be a little more suited to you and
so it's this kind of pathway right it's
like maybe the goal you should be
attaining is here
but you don't know that because you're
clueless and so you aim there well it's
better than there
and it's not
nothing it's not cessation of movement
and you know if you if you're supposed
to go there and you go here
but you walk diligently towards it
you're a little closer once you get to
here than you were here and it's this
oscillating self-corrective process that
leads you to the final star
and you have to be willing to engage in
erroneous experimentation to
to manage that but it is a
self-correcting process and so one of
the things i always talk to my clients
about is well
but let's try something
you know and and and we'll reserve to
ourselves the right to alter our
trajectory
and then i would use as a corrective
there because you might say well how do
you know when you're not just giving out
right instead of thinking maybe you need
a different goal and i would say well
you can
if you're really concerned about your
proclivity for self-deception
you can enter into a contract with
yourself that you won't replace any goal
you've set with a goal that's easier
and so you can switch your goal but it
has to be a little harder so that you
check yourself against that tendency to
withdraw and avoid and be self-deceptive
and
that works like a charm and if you do
that
with some degree of diligence
your goals will get better and more
attainable and you'll get happier too
because
you don't experience happiness except in
relationship to a goal and that's really
worth knowing
you know and that's another thing to
think about too if your life is
meaningless
well you're not pursuing a valued goal i
mean you might be depressed too and
sometimes that can be like an illness
you know something that is really wrong
with you but a good rule of thumb is
that if you find no joy in life
there's a very low probability that
you're pursuing a goal that you regard
intrinsically like in the depths of your
temperament that's worthwhile
and that's technically true because we
do in fact experience most of the
positive emotion let's say that's
associated with with uh with emotions
like joy we experience that in
relationship to a goal
so well then you want to find a goal
that regulates your negative emotion and
that brings you a certain amount of
positive emotion and that expands your
competence as you pursue it and you will
experience that as meaningful that's
really what meaning signals meaning
signals you're doing all those things
you say well that's not real it's like
don't listen to the semantic chatterbox
so much
right there's levels of you that are far
wiser than that and you can watch what
happens to you instead of noticing what
you think
the goal of life
is to live a life which in retrospect we
are glad that we lived
it's important to give ourselves
perspective
to develop that metacognizance to step
away from the urgent to step away from
the phenomenological day-to-day
existence because the present self is a
petulant child
it's lazy and it wants the path of least
resistance and that glass of wine and
that new movie on netflix and the couch
looks really comfortable
very rarely does it yeah well that's the
danger with impulsive happiness is that
it does have that present bound quality
and in retrospect
that can lead to a life that's not well
lived
generally that yes
yes
yes
life
definitely places
philosophical demands on you
whether you wanted to or not
and so it is useful to step back i mean
that's likely why
the trade openness evolved that's the
creativity dimension that's the
dimension that that allows people to
engage in philosophical discourse and to
think laterally and it does allow you to
step back and look at things on a
broader scale
and to generate creative alternatives
the problem with examining your
assumptions is it's very disquieting
you know because
you want things to
act the way you predict and desire them
to act
and you work within a set of axioms and
you act them out in order to maintain
that
predictability
that desirable predictability
if you mess around the more fundamental
the axiom that you question the more
uncertainty you release
and some of that can be positive but a
plenty of it can be anxiety provoking i
mean just imagine that you're in a
relationship and
you know it's it's maybe a year into it
you haven't formalized and finalized it
but then one day you allow yourself to
ask the question is this the
relationship i want to be in
well that's a fundamental question but
just imagine now you're destabilizing
your entire future
you're destabilizing your present you're
destabilizing your past because
while engaging in the relationship
you're acting out the assumption that
it's the proper relationship but now you
question that that means the story you
told yourself about what was happening
while it happened
even though it's already happened was
wrong and something else had happened
and then you have to think through what
actually happened so it's unbelievably
demanding and the more axiomatic the
assumption the more
certainty is cast into into troublesome
chaos now you could say yeah
but the alternative is worse
and i believe that often that's true but
but the thing about the alternative is
that you can always forestall it right
that question tomorrow
you bet you bet and it's a very powerful
temptation and no wonder
you know do you want to dig up the body
now or do you want to wait a month it's
like well it'll be more rotten in a
month but
but it's not a month it's not now right
it's not now
and so i i understand why people don't
want to delve into things even if their
emotions indicate that they should
i mean i would see this all the time if
you're trying to settle an important
issue with your partner let's say
that can be a tremendously
troublesome
excavation process
and there's no shortage of pain but
if you sort it out then maybe things can
be better it doesn't mean it's easy or
or or uh
or pleasant
quite the contrary it's like surgery
it's not it's like surgery to remove
something you know that shouldn't be
there
it's necessary but man
still surgery on that point of
understanding my inadequacies or
someone's inadequacies i i really
believe um that it's really difficult to
undergo self-development if you don't
have self-awareness and i was i was
really trying to understand from your
writings how someone is to build their
self-awareness it's almost like the
unknown unknown if you don't have it how
do you build the thing i know a good
exercise for that
it's like a prayer in some sense in fact
i would say it's proper prayer if you
want to know something about yourself
sit on your bed one night and say to
yourself you've got to mean this like
you've got to be desperate this is no
game this
it's like
my life is not everything i want it to
be
and perhaps it's not everything that i
need it to be and by need i mean my life
is so unbearable that
the suffering that's attended upon that
is make me nihilistic cynical bitter
resentful homicidal genocidal
unable to have a good relationship pro
prone to punish people for their virtues
because of my jealousy
uh
driving the proclivity to see evil
everywhere except within my own heart
like these are problems man
and
you ask yourself you sit on the bed and
say okay man i'm ready to
learn something like what
what's one thing i'm doing wrong
that i know i'm doing wrong
that i could fix
that i would fix
it's like
you meditate on that you'll get an
answer
and it won't be one you want but it'll
be the necessary one
you know and it's often
something that will point you to small
things
so carl jung said people in the modern
world don't see god because they don't
look low enough
and so imagine you're in your messy
bedroom
you know and you're sitting on the edge
of the bed trying to have an honest
dialogue with yourself and the little
voice says you know it's pretty
disgusting in here and you think well
i'm way above such trivial niceties as
organizing my room
it's like
well that's pride that's arrogance
if you're above
organizing what's actually yours
how in the world are you ever going to
organize anything else and so you get on
your knees and you think
well it's time to
you know
take a brush to the toilet and maybe
that's where you start
and so and that works like that works
you start making those micro
improvements like real micro
improvements real on the ground actual
micro improvements to things you know
that are wrong you'll improve
unbelievably rapidly thoughts on the
drug epidemic
well i'm not sure there is an epidemic
any more than there always has been i
know that there is now
a tilt towards drugs
in the us in particular like meth and
and
fentanyl and the other opiates and
that's quite a catastrophe
a lot of that is occurring among people
who don't have
meaning in their lives i would say you
might think that's a facile answer but
it's not you know like here here's the
rat literature like it's if you take a
rat lab rat
typical lab rat is you know genetically
bred uh
to be identical with many other lab rats
and he lives alone in a cage and
he he's got a pretty miserable rat life
because rats are social animals and they
don't like to live in cages by
themselves and you can get a lab rat in
a cage addicted to cocaine in no time
flat and he'll still like press a lever
for cocaine reward
pretty much to the ex to the exclusion
of all else including sex and often
including food but if you take that same
rat
and you put him in a rat family you know
in a rat social hierarchy in a rat
environment and give him something that
rat rat like to do so that he can be
satisfied it's very difficult to get him
addicted to cocaine and so i would say
the reason that people take psychomotor
stimulants and all the drugs of serious
abuse are psychomotor stimulants
regardless of what else they might be
they activate the dopaminergic system
which is the system that tracks
reward and that that is associated
that's activated when you pursue
valuable goal-directed behavior
if you don't have that if you don't have
a valid goal if you don't have so no no
real valid meaning in your life you
don't have a valid ambition then you
don't have any way of activating that
system and why the hell wouldn't you
take drugs it's like you have to have
something better to do to not addict
yourself you know so
so i would say that a huge part of the
current epidemic in in the us in
particular is is manifest among broken
men who have no real place in society
and providing them with money isn't
going to help that they need a
productive and meaningful existence and
which is the paramount the paramount
goal should be the paramount goal of
social
of social policy for example we it isn't
the alleviation of poverty that's really
the issue because people in the west
aren't poor there might be a bit of a
distribution problem but we're not poor
what we have is a
uh
what would you say a
we have a problem of meaningful
engagement and that's what has to be
addressed and that's why i do the work
that i'm doing how much do people have
to kind of date around to find somebody
though because it does take a bit of
exploration to find somebody you're
compatible with so what's a reasonable
amount of exploration and like by what
age should people have
figured it out because i mean there's
always the grass looks greener
so at some point maybe you should just
settle down but what are your thoughts
on that
well life isn't very long
and so you don't get to evaluate that
many relationships you probably only
have a five to ten year period to do
that something like that and then
the reason you only have that amount of
time is because it gets more and more
difficult as you get older rather than
easier partly because people your age
are increasingly in relationships so i
would say get at it don't don't
overestimate the degree to which you
have to
find someone versus
create the relationship you know there's
many cultures and i'm not i'm not
suggesting that this is necessarily a
desirable alternative
but there are many cultures that arrange
marriages
and those arranged marriages frequently
work it's not obvious that they work
less frequently than
relationships or marriages that are
predicated on romantic attraction
um which has its own pitfalls
is that no matter who you find they're
going to be full of flaws like you are
and so a lot of it is something you
create i think you want to find someone
you can trust and someone that you're
attracted to and perhaps someone who
shares the same ambitions
as you do or at least has ambitions that
are compatible with yours and then
well then pretty much all of it after
that is what you create rather than what
you find
is part of the reason that arranged
relationships or arranged marriages work
is part of it because there's a societal
pressure to not get divorced and because
it's somebody your parents have chosen
um there might be an expectation that
you're supposed to uphold of course i
mean that's partly why marriages in the
west work too are marriages and cultures
where
the primary impetus for the marriage is
romantic or sexual attraction
part of the reason those marriages works
is because work is because of social
pressure
it it's very difficult to sustain a
relationship across time and you need
all sorts of social institutions
as well as conceptual schemes operating
to help ensure that that's the case
because life is so difficult you're
going to go through periods of time
where your relationship is
extraordinarily difficult but there's no
escaping that and
if the pressure
to stay together wasn't there
the relationship might fragment
prematurely and then not only would you
have your problems you'd also not have
any relationships and that's not helpful
so
you go through thick and thin together
and it can be very thin the thin times
can be very thin
but
the the collective judgment of the human
race so far has been that long-term
monogamous relationships are the best
that you can manage
and that's true cross-culturally with
there are exceptions polygamy is
is
relatively common nowhere near as common
as monogamy but there are exceptions
made for polygamy
but
the problem with polygamous societies is
that they tend to be more violent
especially
the young men in them tend to be more
violent because they are more shut out
of the mating game and that makes them
very frustrated oh that makes sense so
it'd be mostly yeah that makes sense
that'd make me pissed off too
why is this once this guy over here have
seven wives he'd be better off dead
yes yes and i might be the one to help
them along with that yeah
i mean that's
part of what monogamy does is stabilize
societies and that means that fewer
stable in stable societies fewer people
die
and so
all things considered
our species has decided that that's a
good trade-off how is it the discipline
and the straight and narrow offer the
best chance for a good life and and
how is it that we have forgotten
that is the case
well the reason that discipline is
necessary is because
you're a mass of competing short-term
interests
and so the question is then well which
short-term interest should win out
and the answer to that is well
none of them they need to be organized
into a hierarchy
that makes them functional across time
and across individuals so like a
two-year-old is very likely to act out
his or her
proximal impulse but of course a
two-year-old can't survive in the world
you have to regul you have to bring your
your
primary instincts let's say
under the regulatory structure of a
higher order value system that allows
them to manifest themselves without
undue mutual sacrifice across large
spans of time in the presence of large
numbers of other people so that requires
a very sophisticated ordering it's like
we already talked about the fact that a
meta-narrative is necessary to unite
subcultures say so that they can operate
peacefully and harmoniously within the
same space the same thing applies within
you because you're like an you're an
internal coalition of warring
single-minded tribes
and they have to all be brought under
the organizational structure of
long-term collective vision let's say
and in order to do that you have to be
disciplined and any discipline
speaking you know
technically speaking is an attempt to
bring all those competing short-term
impulses under a large a larger scale
and more inclusive framework
and so you do that and then well that's
actually what gives you freedom
being impulsive and being free aren't
the same things because if you're
impulsive you're just the slave of your
impulses right
there's no freedom in that that's that's
just that's the same freedom so to speak
literally that a two-year-old has
because a two-year-old isn't socialized
yet
so it's not
it's a completely
it that doesn't function in this in the
sophisticated world it doesn't work
right everyone knows it my father gave
me an abiding and then the other thing i
should say about him is he spent a
tremendous amount of time with me when i
was very young say before i was five or
six he taught me to read he did that
every night for months and i remember
that very vividly and instilled in me a
love of books and a fluency in reading
he
believed that i could do
what i set my mind to
and he really believed that and to have
someone that believed that
of you
that's something man
and you know it was something that i
wanted to offer to my clinical clients
you know because i did believe that
there was more to them than the
suffering person that was sitting there
and that you know with joint diligent
effort we could sift our way through the
chaff and find the wheat and that things
could be better and one of the lovely
things about practicing as a clinician
was that
that was that almost inevitably happened
sometimes really radically and
and then of course later it started
started to happen on a broader scale and
i was seeing that happen in the lives of
maybe thousands of people and so pick up
your damn suffering
and bear it
and try to be a good person so you don't
make it worse
well that's a truth
you know
i read a lot about
the terrible things that people have
done to each other you just cannot even
imagine it
it's so awful
so you don't want to be someone like
that now do you have a reason to be yes
you have a lots of reasons to be god
there's reasons to be resentful about
your existence everyone you know is
gonna die
you know you too
there's gonna be a fair bit of pain
along the way a lot of it's going to be
unfair it's like yeah no wonder you're
resentful it's like act it out and see
what happens
you make everything you're complaining
about infinitely worse
there's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is some stupid son of
a [ __ ] like you could figure out a way
to make it a lot worse
so you think well
what do you do about that
well you accept it that's what life is
like it's suffering that's what the
religious people have always said life
is suffering yes
well who wants to admit that well just
think about it well so what do you do in
the face of that suffering
try to reduce it
start with yourself what good are you
get yourself together for christ's sake
so that when your father dies you're not
whining away in a corner and you can
help plan the funeral and you can stand
up solidly so that people can rely on
you that's better don't be a damn victim
of course you're a victim
jesus obviously
put yourself together
and then maybe if you put yourself
together you know how to do that you
know what's wrong with you if you'll
admit it you know there's a few things
you could like polish up a little bit
that you might even be able to manage in
your insufficient present condition and
so you might shine yourself up a little
bit and then your eyes will be a little
more open then you can shine yourself up
a little bit more and then maybe you
could bring your family together instead
of having them be the hateful spiteful
neurotic infighting batch that you're
like doomed to spend christmas with
so then you fix yourself up a little bit
kind of humbly because you know god
you're a fixer-upper if there ever was
one
and then you got to figure out well can
you figure out how to make peace with
your idiot brother and probably not
because he's just as dumb as you so how
the hell are you going to manage that
and so then you maybe you get somewhere
that way and your family's sort of
functioning and you find out well that
kind of relieved a little bit of
suffering although it reduced the
opportunities for spiteful revenge and
that's kind of a pain in the neck and so
then you get your family together a
little bit and you're a little clued in
then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult you're a little wiser and so
then maybe you could put a tentative
finger out beyond the family and try to
change some little thing without
wrecking it it's like our society is
complex and we teach our students that
they could just fix it it's like go fix
a military helicopter and see how far
you get with that it's like you're going
to get a dude you're like a chimp with a
wrench whack oh look it's better it's
like no
it's not better things are complicated
and to fix things is really hard and you
have to be like
a golden tool to fix things and you're
not
so
and that's the other message of the west
it's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life
and i'm not saying it's only the message
of the west
how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it
well that's hard
it takes responsibility and i think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
everything you do matters
that's the definition of a meaningful
life but everything you do matters
you're gonna have to carry that with you
or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and
then you don't have any responsibility
because who the hell cares and you can
wander through life doing whatever you
want gratifying impulsive desires for
how useful that's going to be and you're
stuck in meaninglessness but you don't
have any responsibility which one do you
want
well ask yourself which one are you
pursuing and you'll find very rapidly
that it isn't the majority of your soul
that's pursuing the whole meaning thing
because well look what you have to do to
do that you have to take on the fact
that life is suffering you have to put
yourself together in the face of that
well that's hard i stopped wasting time
that helped a lot i stopped drinking
i stopped going to bars i really didn't
spend a lot of time with my friends when
i had young kids in particular i had
friends and i i saw them you know with
some degree of regularity but
where i cut corners was more with
social life outside my family so i spent
a lot of time with my wife and i spent a
lot of time with my kids and i spent a
lot of time on my career and so you have
to make choices and i think those are
reasonable choices i'm not displeased
with them don't abandon your friendships
but
but you can certainly look at where
you're wasting time and just stop
doing things that you know to be a waste
of time
so and i did and so i had enough room
for my marriage and i had enough room
for my kids and i had enough room for my
career and you know sort of a
multi-dimensional career and i was
always a challenge to me too to see how
efficient i could get
um and you could also
and i've really recommended this for
relatively higher income dual income
couples who are trying to pursue dual
careers kids and marriage you can
outsource you know hire hire a cleaning
lady if you can afford it um
buy restaurant food if you can afford it
etc no you can outsource get you can
have someone do your laundry then you
can concentrate on your marriage and
your kids i know that that you know is
only an avenue available to people who
have relatively high incomes but people
who have dual incomes have relatively
high incomes and so
outsource what's unnecessary so that you
can concentrate on what's necessary i
mean i didn't do that when i was
beginning my career because
when i lived in the united states when i
was in my late 20s and starting my
family we had one income
you'd think a harvard beginning
professor makes a lot of money and i
suppose that's true
in some absolute sense but relatively
speaking you know we didn't have enough
money to buy magazines we we all our
money went for
for housing cost and and the basic
necessities of living i had a car that
was 20 years old
25 years old i think it was old it was a
bloody thing the doors fell apart on the
person i sold it to you know like six
months down the road they knew it was a
wreck at that point but
we drove that thing right into the
ground so i know that's not necessarily
possible for everyone at the beginning
of their career but if you have two
incomes you can manage it
i
concentrated on my marriage and making
time for it i concentrated on spending
time with my kids consciously and i
concentrated on developing my career
those were the three elements of my life
and i had some time left over for
creative pursuits and
and and for friends but
most of it was a matter of getting rid
of
time wastes of any sort you know and i
just
pushed that out of my life you know day
after day until i wasn't wasting any
time
or virtually no time and you know i've
asked my undergraduates frequently how
much time they waste per day and general
estimates are like six to eight hours of
time they regard themselves as wasting
like that's a whole career right there
right so if you just stop wasting time
you can do a tremendous amount
especially if you also try to maximize
efficiency
and i always found that incredibly
motivating
you know a motivating
game
how much can i do in the least amount of
time possible that was that's fun to try
to do that as far as i'm concerned i
know you know that's maybe undoubtedly a
temperamental thing
but
but if you're built if you're wired that
way that's a great
meta strategy become efficient i always
ask my graduate students when they were
designing experiments they'd come with a
proposal i'd say to them you know is
there any way you could do this 10 times
faster what would you have to cut what
would you have to change to do this 10
times faster
and
you can learn to do that i also learned
to
force the task to fit the time you know
there's this dictum work expands to fill
the time allowed for its completion
work expands
to fill the time allowed for its
completion well there's a
corollary to that which is
work
becomes more efficient in proportion to
the restrictions of time placed upon it
so if you say
well this could take me two weeks but
i'm going to do the best job i could in
one day
you'd be amazed you can get 90 of the
way or 95 of the way or sometimes even
farther in that day
so that's another way of becoming
efficient you know if you only have 10
minutes to do something that should
maybe take you two hours
maybe you can figure out how to do it in
10 minutes you can get dreadfully
efficient
so
that's very much worthwhile in my
estimation if you want to do a lot of
things what what else are you going to
do
you know rather than become efficient if
you want to do many things you don't
have much choice but it i found it
extremely entertaining to try to do that
and when i was healthy
i could do a tremendous amount in a very
short period of time
i'm very frustrated that that's not so
much the case now although perhaps it's
coming back to some degree what is the
best way if i've got a friend in my life
or a you know partner that i want to
encourage to
come out of their place of despair into
a better place how do i effectively do
that without overpowering them or
stifling them or making them feel
inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love
well
example's good
but then i would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person
you don't not only do you not know you
actually don't want that responsibility
for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice well they
pay the price for that
and you can skip away merrily and say
well i should have spoke more carefully
it's like you don't mess about with
people's destiny you do not know where
they're headed now having said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know
like how are you feeling
i'm not doing so good today well
you know
what's up what's going on
and you can't think well i'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see
what it is that you want to know because
see this when people ask me questions
after my lectures you know now now and
then
or during a q a now and then people get
up and they'll ask a real question it's
part of the ongoing dialogue something
struck them they stand up there's
something they really want to know it's
an honest question and that goes real
well but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so i get this from
christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is corner me
into admitting that i should accept
jesus christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say
denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so
your questions like your statements your
question should be honest and
if you ask people questions and you
really listen
they will untangle themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know
like
if i meet people on the street you know
i ask them their name
they're all usually flustered when they
come up to me they don't really want to
interrupt me and then they're flustered
and the first thing i do is shake their
hand and ask them their name and i
listen you know not that good at
remembering names but
i listen to it and and they know how to
say their name and so it kind of settles
them down and then it sort of marks them
out as a person against the background
eh
and then if i pay attention to them and
listen they will tell me something in
like 10 seconds that i need to know
because they're they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is i don't know where
you're headed i don't know what's wrong
with you
this is a hard problem man it's like
what's your problem
i don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now i wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if i could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and i wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way
what is it that i would have to say or
do that would in principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well i think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then i will say
what words should i use
and they'll say well if you loved me
you'd know and i would say no i'm stupid
and ignorant and i don't know
what the right words are to satisfy you
so why don't you give me a hand with
that and all utter them inelegantly and
awkwardly
in a good faith demonstration of my
commitment to peace and that won't be so
good because maybe it would have been
better if i came up with it myself but
maybe next time i can do slightly better
and that works it it
requires the person who's after you
to think through
the question even of
whether there's anything that
could be said or done that would satisfy
them and if the answer to that is no
well probably the relationship is over
but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually
almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it
you know stupidly and badly
so
listening man
jimmy carr i talked to jimmy carr two
weeks ago the famous comedian yeah it
was real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of
of the entertainment forms and i thought
well what do you mean by that because
you're just talk
it's a monologue right now i do
monologues but i pay attention to the
audience right i'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching their reactions and listening
to the audience as a whole so even
though it's a lecture let's say or a
talk
i'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually in
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're they're corpus of potentially
funny jokes
and then they do 200 shows in front of
small audiences
and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening you collect all
the jokes that people laugh at if you do
that 200 times you have nothing but
hilarious material
but you listened
and then you can go out on the road and
that was very interesting to me because
humor is a mysterious
phenomenon experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and elevate ourselves
at the same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them aim yourself in
one direction and
i had a rule with my clients because you
know you might say well i've gone
halfway down this path and i found out
it's wrong
so how do you distinguish that from just
giving up well that's a really hard
question right it's it's a moral hazard
because it's inappropriate to continue
in a direction you now realize to be
wrong but it's also inappropriate to
give up and
use that rationalization as an excuse
and how do you distinguish especially
seeing as we're not transparent to
ourselves well right exactly so that is
genuinely a moral hazard so one of the
principles that i tried to abide by in
my therapeutic discussions was you can
change course as long as the next thing
you do is equally or more difficult
because that's a check against just
giving up
so
you want to discipline yourself so you
can get yourself organized so that you
can go in a particular direction so that
when you find the right direction you
can really go in that direction and that
does require an apprenticeship of sorts
and it it might not matter in some sense
exactly what the apprenticeship is
as long as
it is
rigorous
right and so that's sort of a bridge
between moral relativism and moral
absolutism
there's lots of games you can play
it's not that obvious a priori which is
the best game so that's kind of a
morally relative stance there's multiple
playable
games
but then the absolute is yeah but you
have to play one of them you have to
learn to play one of them have become an
expert at at least one of them
and then that's not a relative
proposition
and i i believe that's true
that seems to me to be the case so you
want to commit to something
and then you you have when you commit to
something you
require yourself to
bring all of your disparate disparate
components
moving in a single direction united in a
single direction so it's a unifying it's
a unifying act
and then once having been unified
well then you can bring that unity to
bear on a variety of different tasks but
you have to bring it together first
so and that that makes sense
developmentally you see children start
out
as a disparate bundle of motivations and
emotions sort of warring with one
another
and then they can integrate that into
single games that they can play with
themselves
and then they integrate that with games
they start to play with other people and
all of that is integration it's not
subjugation it's not repression not if
it's a good game it's integration you
want to get integrated because then you
have
all the horses that are pulling your
chariot pulling in the same direction
and you're much more likely to get to
where you want to go then and also much
more likely to specify a good place to
go
so
that's another re that's something else
conservatives have to teach young people
which is well get yourself disciplined
well why
well not so you're a slave but so that
you could be a master
to use a terminology that you're not
supposed to use anymore but you know
this is in relationship to yourself
not to others
so
yeah and to begin with you have to
accept an external master
because
you just don't have the wisdom to do
that for yourself or the ability or the
opportunity often
everybody knows this
you know they feel bad when they
they decide they're going to put get
themselves in good shape and go to the
gym and lasts like three
days attempts yeah
and then
no one's happy about the fact that they
quit
and they berate themselves for it and we
know that we need to go through a
disciplinary process we need to
subjugate ourselves to a disciplinary
process that's part of the problem with
the constant harping about the you know
oppressive patriarchy
you need a disciplinary process
so
well that's just oppression and slavery
it's like no it's not
no more than a game is
no not a good game a good game isn't
oppression and slavery you're going to
have to put some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in neuroticism you want security
okay so those are all sources of
potential motivation that you could draw
on that you could tailor to your own you
know your own personality but then there
are dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to auger down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the micro processes become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is well you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want you want to
specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer that has to be because you've
determined by some
means that it's worthwhile
and then the next question might be well
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be well you could
consult your own temperament and the
other would be well you kind of look at
how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you when i was 25
or so i probably weighed about 138
pounds i smoked like pack cigarettes day
i drank tremendous amount of alcohol i
was from northern alberta this rough
little town up in northern alberta
called fairview and you know there were
long winters there and my friends were
heavy drinkers and most of them dropped
out of school by the time they were 15
or 16 went off to work on oil rigs and
you know it was a rough town and we
drank a lot i started when i was 14 and
you know um
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together
and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i
i quit smoking oh that took a long time
because i eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and i started working out starting
playing sports which i'd never done i
had a fine time when i was a kid and but
uh i needed really to get disciplined
i had to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since
i was probably about 18 maybe even
earlier than that
got to the point around 25 when i was in
graduate school trying to get my phds
doing all my research like i published
15 papers by the time i graduated with
my phd which was by i think by a fairly
large measure the most papers that any
un graduate student at that time had
ever published at mcgill i think that's
right might have been twice as many or
maybe twice as many maybe even three
times as many and at the same time i
wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my
what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so
you know i had to stop that's a
sacrifice i had to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
becoming more articulate is definitely i
would say
that's the primary
array of weapons
so i mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well
but
the same thing replicated at the level
of the ability to communicate and think
that's a
way broader field of of battle and
opportunity
so
this is one thing that isn't taught well
especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
i would say because they're more
uh
skeptical of such of the educational
enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
and agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their iq and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so
what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to marshal your arguments right
some
battlefield metaphor
to get everything in order
get all your information straight
no to marshall your forces
so i mean that's part of the reason that
rap
artists are so popular especially among
disaffected young men black and white
alike
because they're unbelievably articulate
they have this incredible verbal prowess
it's unbelievably attractive you know
and it's associated with genuine
artistic
and redemptive
activity
often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the
underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that people think
that the purpose of memory is to
remember the past
and that's not the purpose of memory the
purpose of memory is to extract out from
the past lessons to structure the future
and that that's the purpose of personal
memory and so you're done with a memory
when you've extracted out the
information that you can use to guide
yourself properly in the future so if
you have a traumatic memory for example
that's really obsessing you if you
analyze that memory to the point where
you figured out how you put yourself at
risk and you can determine how you might
avoid that in the future then the
emotion associated with that goes away
so memory is a has a very pragmatic
function
and cultural memory is the same thing
is that we need to extract out stories
from our past that structure our future
and we need that because
first of all if you don't have a purpose
let's say
it isn't that your life becomes neutral
in a meaningless sense it's that your
life becomes characterized by unbearable
suffering because the baseline condition
of life is something like unbearable
suffering and what you have to say
against that is a noble and worthwhile
purpose and hopefully
hopefully your determination of that
purpose is buttressed to some degree by
the wisdom of the past because you can't
conjure something like that up on your
own
and if you provide people with nobility
of purpose then they can tolerate the
suffering of existence without becoming
entirely corrupted by it and cultures
that don't do that
it isn't even so much that they die it's
that cultures that don't do that are
dead they're done
they don't have a story anymore they
don't have a call to adventure and then
well then everyone suffers stupidly as a
consequence it's a very bad thing so
churchill made the same observation that
many of the great psychologists and
philosophers made in the early part of
the 20th century it's like bring the
story forward and
and propagate it and make it the most
noble possible story and then you
motivate people to do to transcend
themselves which they need to do
so yes he's exactly right in his
diagnosis there's an entire what
literature psychoanalytic literature on
the dangers of over compassion hyper
protectiveness helicopter parenting all
of that when you have children you have
to encourage them you have to encourage
them to take risks
because they have to grow up and take
their place in the world you can't
protect them too much because if you do
you destroy them that's the motif of
hansel and gretel right two kids lost in
the woods
they find the gingerbread house that's a
little bit too good to be true right
it's not only shelter when you need it
but it's candy what lives inside the
house that's too good to be true the
witch that devours you
right that's excess compassion
so you don't want your mother to do
everything for you that's for sure
there's a rule if you're dealing with
the elderly and like extended care homes
don't do anything for your clients that
they can do themselves
because you undermine their autonomy and
so there's a certain amount of harshness
that goes along with that just as there
is if you're a good mother because you
have to separate yourself from your
child and allow them to make hurtful
mistakes
right i mean it's very difficult if
you're a compassionate person to stand
back far enough to let your children
take necessary risks but one thing i'm
not getting there's a big difference
between letting people do something for
themselves
and saying men should be dangerous
by dangerous that implies i should be
ready to threaten someone to hurt
somebody no you should be capable of it
but that doesn't mean you should use it
there's nothing to you otherwise like if
you're not a formidable force there's
not there's no morality in your
self-control
if you're incapable of violence not
being violent isn't a virtue people who
teach martial arts know this full well
right if you learn a martial art you
learn to be dangerous but simultaneously
you learn to control it both of those
come together and the combination of
that capacity for danger and the
capacity for control is what brings
about the virtue otherwise you confuse
weakness with with moral virtue i'm
harmless therefore i'm good it's like no
that isn't how it works that isn't how
it works at all if you're harmless
you're just weak and if you're weak
you're not going to be good you can't be
because it takes strength to be good
well it's a hierarchy of virtue i would
say you know there's an old idea that
god is the sum
of all that's good
i don't think some is exactly the right
metaphor it's more like imagine there
are eternal verities truth beauty
justice love
courage
fortitude
compassion
think of all those things as virtues
so virtue is what all virtues have in
common virtue is what all virtues have
in common
that's the relationship of god to the
good
god is
the essence of the good
so let me put that aside for a moment
or you may think how would that manifest
itself
in your life well that might be pursuit
of the good and that's the pursuit of
the good that unites all proximal goods
and
what is that exactly well it's something
like the
belief that it would be for the best
that all things flourish to the degree
that that's possible when when i was a
clinician i thought of that as the good
in
me serving the best in my clients
and i think the desire for that to
happen that's love
so that's the desire
for
you say well you take a human bent
broken miserable malevolent
hurt corrupt weak
pathetic contemptible
frustrating disappointing
all of those things that we can lay on
ourselves because of our inadequacies
it's like
it's easy to dismiss that and part of
that dismissal is
what drives the notion that the planet
has too many people on it and that we're
a cancer on the face of the earth
it's like it's not easy to love that
but what do you want you want the broken
people to rise up
out of their brokenness
rather than despise them for it
and then you orient yourself towards
that and try to pull that out of people
and yourself and
and
that you have to have that frame
first that's what you're aiming for and
maybe
that would be the opposite of hell this
is one thing i would say that unites sam
harris and i despite our differences in
in belief in some sense at the level of
detail sam is very acutely aware of the
reality of malevolence and hell now he
wouldn't frame that metaphysically or
religiously but it doesn't really matter
that he is doing his best
to aim away from that as hard as he
possibly can i didn't realize the last
time i talked to him that sam identified
the religious
tradition the dogmatic religious
tradition with the totalitarianism that
produces atrocity now i think that's a
misidentification the same way the
marxists blame
inequality on capitalism inequality is
really a problem
but it's not the fault of capitalism and
totalitarian atrocity is really a
problem but to identify that reflexively
with religion
or even with religious dogma that's a
mistake
dogma maybe but even that's tricky
because what's the difference between
dogma and knowledge you know today's
knowledge is tomorrow's dogma and
drawing the line between those two is
extremely difficult you can't just
abandon everything you think even though
it's arbitrary
you need it to guide you
and it can transform into totalitarian
dogma and
promote atrocity in the servants of in
the service of its no longer valid
maintenance
but
that's a very complicated problem life
has proximal meanings right
there's the meaning that you
experience when you're engaged in a
piece of art or when you're reading or
when you're engrossed in a movie or in a
conversation
there's the meaning that emerges
within your relationships with people
that you cherish
or are enthusiastic with
there's meanings of security and
predictability
there's meanings of
duty and responsibility and active
engagement with your job and your career
um there's meanings of aesthetic
pleasure
now
all of those have their value
and each of them has their place
and you know maybe there's a hierarchy
of value there as well so that some of
those meanings are deeper than others
and then you might say well what
characterized the deepest of all
meanings and it would be something like
relationship with the transcendent and
that would establish a relationship
between you and
what's always been conceptualized is god
which is
generally supposed to be something
ineffable right it's not definable but
you might think about it as the central
animating
spirit of the age or the value around
which all other values are organized or
the wisdom of the ages or the creative
spirit that possesses you when you're
inspired or
what grips you
with enthusiasm
at a sports event or at a musical event
all of those things and
we need a relationship with that
and
we find our deepest meaning in that
relationship and if we don't find it
i think if we don't find it in something
that's
explicitly
religious
then we tend to magnify something of
lesser value say something political
into that
to fill the void
so yes life has proximal meanings
without god without eternity but
at the ultimate level something's
lacking
and it's the desire to fulfill that lack
that and maybe the lack itself that's
part and parcel of the religious
instinct
so
you can kill god
but you can't
that doesn't rectify the hunger for god
and then that hunger seeks out
replacements that's how it looks to me
so
and then you know you you might also say
well does that mean you have to believe
in god and
i don't think of
the proper answer to that is that
you need to agree with a propositional
statement does god exist yes
no like does this is this table there
yes
it's not that kind of
relationship it's characterized in the
old testament as a struggle so israel
means those who struggle with god
and
you have to participate in that struggle
and you can do that weirdly enough as a
believer as a non-believer
maybe sometimes more intensely as a
non-believer
the issue might be more paramount than
the issue of virtue and
and the issue of
the ultimate orientation compare
yourself to who you were yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason i wrote that was because i had
this client 10 i'm a clinical
psychologist and i spent 20 hours a week
for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them they are
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and
anyways
um with regards to
um
to uh
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just who someone else
is today um
this old client of mine he was about 85
when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a
a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written he made them out of gold
and he would hand those out and and he
had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that i didn't know about called the
pareto distribution which see i'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that that's a pretty or a normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than very tall or very
short and weight is like that and lots
of things are normally distributed and
psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so here's an example of the
pareto distribution huh you know there's
a rule of thumb that if you run a
company that 20 percent of your
employees do 80 of the work or the 20 of
your customers are responsible for 80 of
your sales or the twenty percent of them
are responsible for eighty percent of
the customer service calls same thing
but that's not exactly the rule the rule
is worse than that the rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work
what if you have a thousand employees
well then it's 30 and if it's 10 000
employees then it's a hundred
and this actually turns out to be a
rather iron-clad rule it it it applies
across very very many situations it
applies for example to the mass of stars
and the size of cities so you can see
how universal it is as a law and it's
it's something like those that have more
get more and those that have less get
less that's the matthew principle right
to those who have everything more will
be given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's rife with
inequality so you know you hear this
idea that i think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom two billion that's a pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law
it's no matter what society you study
you get a pareto distribution of wealth
you get a pareto distribution of number
of records recorded you get a pareto
distribution of number of songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and i'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although i am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
soviet union for example
and in maoist china they were trying at
least in principle to adjust inequality
but the cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but
we do know that it's inevitable and we
also know that we don't know how to
regulate it so there is inequality what
that means is there's always going to be
people around that are better at
something than you are and the and
that's a that's a problem because you
can get jealous and you can get bitter
and you can get resentful and worse you
can get hopeless you know because you
look like look
i have this this friend of mine he told
me something so funny um he was he was
decrying his his lack of success in the
world and he compared himself to his
roommate
and uh
he said you know his roommate his
college roommate was doing much better
than he was and his bloody roommate was
elon musk it's like
really like it's like oh you're not
doing as well as elon musk well it's i
mean you can see it would take it rather
personally because they were roommates
and everything it wasn't like he was
doing badly like he was doing pretty
damn well it's like i'm not as good as
elon musk it's like yeah well you and
like seven billion other people you know
but but i thought it was instructive
because
well because you have to be careful who
you compare yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to aim at one of the
things i've thought about a fair bit is
the
meaning of the sermon on the mount
and as far as i can tell it's it's a
it's basically a two-part
it's two-part wisdom
the first is that you should aim at the
highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so if i wanted what was
good for you say if i genuinely wanted
it i'd want it in a way that was good
for you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and maybe good for me too you
know you could conceive of that as the
desire and i think that's a good
definition of love is that you actually
want the best you want the best possible
outcome and in the gospels of course
that's extended even to your enemies yes
right is that okay if we're going to
have things good let's have it good
enough for even the people that set
themselves up against me because if the
world was running properly things would
be good for them too and that would be
better and it seems to me that that's a
very good way of looking at things it's
a difficult way of looking at things and
then the second
part of the sermon on the mount is
something like
having established that as your aim
which is no easy thing by the way right
because you have to be pretty
clear-headed and single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth and you can
ally so there's truth and love that are
allied together truth love and attention
it's something like that that are all
allied together
um
with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable
if you're plagued by bouts of depression
and anxiety that does destabilize your
identity
so um it's almost by definition but
having said that
look this is when
habit
and plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that i've had
what's sustained some of them were long
and and and certainly the most
unpleasant experiences of my life
um
you this is when you need
a philosophy let's say that's allied
with your vision and your strategy to
sustain you because what what what would
happen to me is that
you know i have these a vision and i
suppose the vision is of a world that's
better in in
that's less likely to descend into
ideological catastrophe and where people
are more responsible and more awake
and more educated and
and and healthier all of that a vision
of a better world you know a world
that's less hellish at least but also a
better world and
some sense of what role i might play in
that
and and so that's very motivating like
it's a profound goal to try to make
things better and you can do that
locally you can do that for yourself you
can do that for your family you can do
that for the broader community and all
of that's worth it man it's worth making
some sacrifices for it's worth suffering
for to some degree
and then you decompose that into the
day-to-day and week-to-week strategies
and actions that you're undertaking the
plans and and and the activities that
you're putting forward to make that
dream a reality to realize it and then
when the depression and anxiety come
along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like
you get up and you
work through the next hour you try to
stay on track you try to implement your
strategic plans to the best of your
ability and you hope and you pray that
you'll get through it
you know you'll get through it and that
the darkness will recede and you
you you stay on track you eat even
though you're not hungry you get up even
though you want to stay in bed you
interact with people even though you'd
rather be alone and it's it's it's it's
the benefit of disciplined habits
can can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm
leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can roll forward and that's what
you've got and so endurance is a huge
part of it and then i would say with its
anxiety it's the same thing it's like
are very much the same as you're
terrified and and uncertain but you move
ahead to the best of your ability and
again you operate at least to some
degree on hope and if you haven't got
hope then you've got blind bloody
endurance
and that's all motivated by some sense
that you're working towards something
that's worthwhile working toward
you know and and that is well that's
your own long-term well-being to treat
yourself properly it's the stability and
productivity and harmony and health of
your family that's a huge deal
and then it's whatever benefit you can
be to the community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward in order to maintain
that pathway then so be it
because
it's better than the alternative when
you're trying to lead people forward out
of the darkness let's say
out of anxiety and depression and
despair and and resentment bitterness
and anger and all of those things
catastrophic
interactions with their family is that
you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them right so basically what
you do instead of saying to them you
know those terrible things that are
happening just ignore those and and find
some peace right get your mind away from
it that is what you say you say turn
around and look at them even more than
you've been looking at them it's very
paradoxical advice but of all the things
that have been proven
to aid people's
recovery and movement towards mental
health that's like at the top of the
list voluntary confrontation with what
you are afraid of or or what you despise
even for that matter and so
jung had an axiom that he derived from
the alchemist which was instir qualis
inventor which meant roughly meant
that which you most need will be found
where you least want to look and that
was also his explanation for why people
weren't enlightened
because you think well the california
approached enlightenment to speak you
know kind of satirically is follow your
bliss it's like well that's easy if that
was the case everyone would be
enlightened but the union approaches no
no no you do what's meaningful and pay
attention follow the truth and it will
take you to the worst place you can
imagine and then maybe there's some
chance for enlightenment soul is also
the center of the world
which is a frightening proposition and
and not one that's easily comprehensible
solzhenitsyn's work in the gulag
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
because he insisted that it was a pre
preconception of our
judeo-christian heritage that each
person was the center of the cosmos and
you can think of that as
a center of consciousness right
a center
from which being itself is not only
reflected but also generated and it was
schnitzen's
belief and dostoevsky's as well and i
think jung would have been in accordance
with this and nietzsche as well
for that matter that
in some manner that we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well
the
outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it i don't understand i know that's
i know that to be true i feel that to be
true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of
intrinsic and equal worth
part of that doctrine is that each
person is has intrinsic and equal
responsibility
and that we're each capable of
generating a fair bit of hell around us
and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good and that the fate of the
world as it careens through
eternity
is actually a consequence of
the
ethical decisions of each of us it's a
terrifying idea
it's no wonder people flee from it into
hedonism let's say and and ideology
because
it's very
frightening
possibility that
the choices that you make day to day
or fail to make
have this profound and lasting effect on
the structure of reality but i don't
really see any way out of that
conclusion you need an ideal because you
have nothing to aim at but an ideal is a
judge and you always fall short of the
ideal so how the hell can you have the
benefits of having an ideal without
having the crushing blow that goes along
with having the judge that always
regards you as insufficient so i was
trying to work that out in the chapter
and this is something i've had to work
out a lot as a clinical psychologist
it's like
well
let's say
you need a goal
but we don't want to let your distance
from the goal crush you so you got to
set up a goal and then you got to make
the goal break the goal down into parts
so that you can move towards it you have
a fairly high likelihood of doing it so
that's a bit of practical i wouldn't say
advice it's it's because it's better
than advice it's it's some practical
knowledge about how to go about
achieving a name set a high aim but
differentiate it down so you know what
the next step is and then make the next
step difficult enough so you have to
push yourself past where you are but
but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success it's
also what you do with children right you
you want to push them because
they need to grow up and be more than
they are right but you don't want to
crush them with constant failure so what
you do is aim high and make the goal
proc difficult but proximal higher on
the basis of competence
using objective tests
and let the cards fall where they're
going to
and don't be afraid to
tell people that that's what you're
doing
watch your hr department carefully and
make sure that they're not pushing
diversity inclusivity and equity
initiatives that they're not requiring
people to
take implicit association tests that
hypothetically reveal their unconscious
bias that they're not doing seminars on
systemic racism and prejudice and then
they're not making the assumption that
unequal outcomes let's say in terms of
hiring in the stem fields or in terms of
employment in the stem fields which by
the way are radically overestimated if
you
unless you gerrymander what constitutes
the definition of a stem discipline
you just have to you have to not
participate in any of that and you have
to make it known to your peers which who
would be other silicon valley founders i
would presume that you're not doing any
of that there's so many rules that are
great but what do you think is probably
if if somebody was to read those books
and there's one rule that you're like
this rule of the 24 i've given you over
these past few years
i you can absolutely not get this one
wrong which rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop
saying things that you know are lies and
that will change your life if you do
that
and it's crazy
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
and you think well i'm just lying to
other people no you're not
you can't just lie to other people
because what you say becomes you
especially if you practice it
because we build ourselves out of words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like
don't don't say things you know to be
false that's a that's a good start man
and it allies yourself with the truth
and that like how can that be a bad idea
imagine that what is true reflects
reality which is sort of the definition
of true how
can failing to align yourself with
reality work how is that possibly going
to work well you say well i can you know
if i lie i get away with something it's
like no you don't
you i i tell you i swear this is true
in all of my clinical practice
i have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see
what your lies cause or too blind or too
self-deceptive you just don't see it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
god
fundamentally that's a very old idea and
it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
i got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's gonna snap back and hit you in the
face and that's that's life man you warp
the structure of reality you think you
are someone who can warp the structure
of reality with your words
and get away with it
really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not god your perceptual
structures are determined by the goals
that you have at hand i mean some of
that's that's not completely true
because your perceptual systems also
have limitations right there's things
you can't see or hear even if you need
to so there are limitations built in but
within that set of limitations you're
still trying to tune your perceptions to
your motivated goals and that's also
very useful to think about when you're
trying to understand artificial
intelligence because for human beings
without goals there's no perception
because there's no filtering mechanism
that you can use to determine the level
of resolution at which you perceive
anyway so there's the there's a thing
made of smaller things which are made
out of smaller things and it's so it's
kind of my iconic representation of the
complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and i think if you
just look at it
you can
detect it's like a necker cube you know
those cubes that
that are line drawings that you can see
the front of and then it'll flip to the
back have you seen those
so this is kind of necker cube like or
at least it is for me in that when i
look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes i focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes i can see these other lines
and then sometimes i'll focus on that
square and sometimes i can see the
little dots there or maybe one dot and
my perceptions are going like this
trying to fit a pattern to it and i you
can kind of detect that when you're
watching it and so i would say well you
have the options of perceiving this in
its full complexity or you can simplify
it
essentially there's lots of ways you can
simplify it but some of them are laid
out there so you take the complex thing
you make a low resolution representation
of it
so that's it's rough that's the rough
area that all those dots occupy that's
the rough area broken down to its four
most fundamental quadrants that might be
how you would look at it if if this was
a map of an orchard and you were trying
to walk from south to north that would
be a useful representation
this combines this and this that's
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself so the first issue is how should
you look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then i think what happens
is we have the thing in itself
and then we simplify it with a
perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when i throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do i
and i'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel
because the novel comes alive in your
imagination in your own idiosyncratic
way and it wouldn't if you didn't
understand the references of the novel
right the novelist has to assume that
your basic perceptual structures and
your intuitions and your instincts are
basically the same as his or hers
because otherwise they have to assume
that because otherwise they would be
lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic often for
example if you start reading victorian
novels you may find that it takes a
while to get into them because the
presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations you have to make a
decision in your life
and this is
this is a decision and i would say that
it's a voluntary element of faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying
here's where i stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you
you know pledge allegiance to a friend
you have a best friend and you want to
maintain that friendship as long as you
possibly can it's it's it's a decision
of faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like i said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe
okay so back to god is love well i'm
going to talk about being first instead
of god
um
and being is the totality of experience
that we're going to define that it that
way for the purposes of this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature
being is what you experience as a
conscious creature it includes all your
emotions all your motivations all your
subjective experience as well as
everything that's objective
okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's
a useful
move of faith to
act as if you love being and if you love
something then you want the best in it
to flourish and so maybe you decide deep
in your soul that
it would be better for you to
act towards an end that
makes everything that's good better that
that's the best way to live to make
everything that's good better and maybe
to restrict the development of
everything that's malevolent and evil
within yourself and in the broader world
and so far as you're able to do that and
so i think that's an expression of love
is that because when you love something
you care for it and the proper attitude
towards being i think is care
and so
so that's one element of god is love god
being
analogous in some way to being
now we could look at god more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you
love other people you want the best for
them you want the best in you to serve
the best in them if you love them and
you trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
i don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take i think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage
and
and so
that's
how that looks to me
is it feeling like loving a person yes i
think it is i think it is a feeling like
loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for
a child your child
your your brother your sister a family
member it's the generalization of that
to the broader
domain of
of existence to broader domain of
domains of existence and i think that's
a skill in some sense right i mean if
you're
good at loving and caring for your
family but you can expand that outward
so that more people are brought under
that umbrella then well assuming you can
manage that it's very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that
and so
you see that when you have a job or you
and you encounter a boss who takes you
under his or her wing and helps develop
you or
you find a teacher who's particularly
inspiring or you work for an
entrepreneur who's inspiring and who
also opens doors for you
um
they're acting with love as far as i'm
concerned they want the best in them to
serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for god's sake
so
can love balance out the crushing
responsibility
that's a sophisticated question
i don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness than sort of a cold
virtue
i don't know if it balances out the
crushing responsibility but i think it's
the emotional analog to the crushing
responsibility
right so maybe there's love and duty and
they run parallel in in if you're an
ethical person that's not all there is
to ethics but you know love and duty
they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities so then you could imagine
i have this cottage
in northern ontario and
we're fortunate
it's dark there and so you can go down
to the dock at night and in the clear
sky you can see the
vast array of the infinite heavens
arrayed above you you know and it's
something that people who live in cities
really don't get to experience anymore
they don't experience the sunset which
we also go out on our boat and watch
pretty much every day
and that puts you in
in touch with what inspires awe
and that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's a deep biological
experience it's
it's
embedded in
the prey responds to a predator in part
you know because if you if you feel aw
sometimes you can feel that with music a
lot of people are high in openness to
experience will feel that quite
frequently under the effect of aesthetic
experiences interestingly enough their
hair stands on end that's pilo erection
that's what a cat does when it's
frightened by a dog like the little boy
at the beginning of the story you know
the cat puffs off to look big to be like
medic hats so it can contend with it can
contend with dogs or at least it could
look like it might and so
when when it sees a dog
the sight of the dog calls the best
fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
[Music]
you know it calls to you
right
dr dawkins sent me a paper
last week
in preparation for a discussion that
we're going to have tomorrow and it was
a very interesting paper and i think i
read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning
animal has to be a microcosm a model of
the environment
within
within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant even your
encounter with mortality your encounter
with finitude and limitation all of that
in relationship to the infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know
and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity it's
time we woke up and realized
what's the most effective way of
overcoming self-deception the problem of
self-deception is extremely thorny
and it's tangled up with the issue of
ignorance as well right how do you know
when you just don't know something and
how do you know when you're being
willfully blind and how do you know when
you're outright lying all of those
things are especially to yourself all of
those things are very complicated
so
to some degree the answer is
well you have to
develop a philosophy
of life
that's detailed
that contains within it
an assessment
of your thoughts about the relationship
between truth and deceit
so
for example
do you believe that it's okay to lie is
it okay to deceive other people to get
what you want are there occasions when
it's okay to deceive other people if
that helps them get what they want so
that would be
an
an instance for example of what people
perhaps call white lies right lies that
are designed to be of benefit are they
appropriate
do you feel that it's okay to deceive
yourself or
or other people
in the pursuit of things that you
believe are valuable
and none of those are trivial questions
and
and they can't be
answered with trivial answers so
to some degree you need
a moral philosophy
that privileges the truth above all else
if you wish to cease engaging in
self-deception
and then you might ask well how would
you develop such a philosophy and some
of that might be
while reading about
moral philosophy
reading literature because it often
deals with questions of good and evil
and deception
thinking about it writing about it
reading about it well i said that
um
and and also contemplating how central
an issue this is for your life how
important is this and
and why is it important if it's
important have you
lied and got into trouble do you believe
that you can lie and get away with it if
you don't believe that you can get away
with it you still engage in it if so why
all right so let's leave the complexity
behind though but but that's a necessary
part of the answer
how do you stop deceiving yourself
assuming that you want to stop doing so
well
i don't believe that you can tell
unerringly when you're telling the truth
i think that some of the time when you
lie outright
you know
and so what i would recommend and have
recommended in my writings in my books
especially in
12 rules for life
the first of my last two books
said tell the truth or at least don't
lie and i added that
codicil to the phrase tell the truth
because it became evident to me when i
was writing that
you know i don't know the truth
certainly not in its fullness
and so
i can't say to someone tell the truth
but i can say
if you believe that the truth is
valuable and if you believe that living
your life according to the dictates of
the truth is for the best for you and
and everyone else let's say
then you could at least stop
lying
and then
i would say
that
as you
pay attention to what you say
so that
your attending to your
deceptive statements and trying to stop
making them
some of them maybe you know outright
they're not true some of them make you
feel uneasy and weak that would be a
less
uh
evident criteria of falsehood but still
a reasonable one
um
you stop doing that
and then
your eye for such things or your ear for
such things or your embodied
capacity to evaluate such things
develops just as everything develops
with practice and your intent which is
to
maintain truth in your speech becomes
sharper and more focused across time and
perhaps you get
as you eliminate the obvious untruths
you get better and better at
detecting the more subtle untruths and
better and better and better and better
at avoiding
being entangled with those as well
so the first
issue i guess is the decision that
it's best
to live in
truth
and then you have to decide how far
you're willing to take that if that
becomes an absolute for example or if
it's a
you know
an important guideline but
you know perhaps to be superseded by
other things
you have to sort that out for yourself
once having established that then i
believe that you
decide
and practice
not lying
and then
possibly if you're fortunate that the
world smiles on you
you'll
engage in less self-deception
i guess the last thing i would add to
that is that there's another form of
self-deception that i wrote about in my
the second of my last two books so the
last one beyond order there's a chapter
in there called don't hide things in the
fog that really deals with
self-deception too so you might say well
there's one form of self-deception that
occurs when you say something that you
know not to be true and pretend even to
yourself that it's true or even act as
if it's true
or base other statements or actions on
it as if it's true
but there's a more subtle form of
self-deception which i think is more
pervasive which is
the unwillingness
to look at or the willingness to turn
away
from evidence that you know would
undermine something that you want to
believe
or make things inconvenient for you
you know i think like a cliched example
is
maybe someone runs a company and they
have a
chief financial officer and they know
that person is not exactly straight
but it's convenient not to look at the
books
so
maybe when they're around
that person they feel guilty and
and uncomfortable
and that's a sign that you know
something's rotten in the state of
denmark so to speak
but then the self-deceptive act is to
not look
where you know you should look
and
you know that's
the sort of thing that people refer to
when they talk about the elephant under
the carpet or the skeleton in the closet
and sometimes to mix metaphors terribly
it's better to let sleeping dogs lie but
often
you know if you have the sense that
there's something more to the story
it's painful and difficult to delve into
it but to not do so
which is the easy route
is a form of
of self-deception a very common
self-deception and
i don't think
my experience as a clinician
in my personal experience as well is
that
when you have a sense that something's
up
and you fail to act
you almost inevitably pay a much higher
price for it at some point deferred into
the future
so you have to think that through for
yourself and ask yourself if you believe
that's true and if it is true unless you
want more trouble in the future then
perhaps you
investigate when
your moral unease let's say
makes alerts you to the fact that
there's something to investigate
wherever i go in the world people come
up to me and they're usually
i wouldn't say they're happy to see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped
desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say i've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over
in some ways you might think well how
could anything better possibly happen to
you than to have people come up to you
all over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like their old
friends so quickly
but
at the same time it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so i wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
and certainly not just happiness it's
better than happiness but it's almost
unbearable look it's good for you to go
take your place in the world have some
ambition have some have a vision have a
goal have a strategy try to try to be a
good person in not not because it's your
duty precisely because that's the proper
way to live we're in danger of
undermining all of that and it's not
good for people one of the things that
i've really learned for example recently
is that there's a or learned to
articulate better is that there's a very
tight relationship between aspiration
and responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what well that's whatever
your aspiration is you have to have an
aim okay well what should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say what why do something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile usually judge
them positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves but you want to be completely
useless so other people have to take
care of you that's pretty pathetic and
maybe you could get your act together so
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and maybe you could even do
better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community there's lots of ways of
defying the crowd let's say i mean
you could live your life the way that
you want to live it that's a matter of
action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is a
inspirational example
so that's not nothing
um
that's that's something live properly
in your defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing
when you when you're debating
because you're taking the manner in
which you act like if you're an
integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
like i don't know this for sure dave you
know but
but generally it's useful how do you do
that um
doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need a value
hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top i would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that the
most appropriate way of interacting with
potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be
at the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and so
the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it
does that in a manner that's evil and
contaminated by malevolence and hatred
and vengefulness then it takes a pathway
that corrupts the world and makes things
worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that
and it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character your life doesn't have meaning
without aspiration or name okay so you
need a hierarchy of values there's got
to be something at the top it's got to
be something important if you don't have
that your life doesn't have any meaning
so if you criticize the hierarchy or
even the ideas of idea of hierarchy you
destroy the idea of aspiration and then
people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily see if you can put
yourself together see what you can do
out in the world while you're waiting to
die it's an all in game it better be
worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility and aspiration
and hierarchy and when you criticize
those things you get rid of the
aspiration you have to negotiate until
you come to the best solution that can
be negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and
if you get upset during the negotiations
which you likely will because these are
difficult topics how to divide up
responsibilities in the house and people
get mad because they feel they've been
taken advantage of or aren't being
listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got the balance
between making peace and speaking the
truth right if the conversation
continues and it can be emotional and
will be and can be difficult because
important things have to be dealt with
but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very useful
to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
gonna agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision is it painful beyond bearing
sometimes yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the central
point holds
okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful
okay so you need a sustaining meaning
well where do you find that
well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and other people
and people ask themselves those
questions when when i'm talking because
i ask them to ask themselves those
questions and
that's the answer well what's meaningful
something that i learned for example
from jean piaget he called that an
equilibrated state and equilibrated
state is like a game that everyone wants
to play and so if you set your household
up properly
then it's a game that everybody is
participating in voluntarily and that's
going to be predicated on the desire for
peace and the willingness to speak truth
and the ability to take responsibility
so that has to be part of your higher
order moral aim
and then when you're having a difficult
discussion with someone
the discussion is going to
be affected by that higher order moral
aim it's not going to be contaminated to
the same degree by your desire to
inflict pain and attain victory and you
know crush your opponent and punish them
for their previous sins and
um
indicate your disappointment things
they've done over the years and all of
that it's hard to say what the soul
means metaphysically because you know
say beyond the cons beyond the confines
of a single human being
we do have this sense that the soul can
expand itself into something that's
greater than
well greater than it has been it has
this capacity for growth
and we do have the sense that the soul
can expand itself to the point where it
it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible to transform
everything that's unnecessarily painful
and malevolent about the world into
what's positive and good and and and
that it does that as a consequence of
confronting the world with courage and
truth and i i think that's right
and i do think that that means that the
soul participates in something eternal
which is the attempt of being itself
to transform what's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
into what's good and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of the reason that our
ancient tradition insists that we're
made in the image of god
and i think that it's a mistake to
underestimate the importance of that
because
i don't think that you can live
life a life of sufficient profundity to
protect yourself from being corrupted by
suffering malevolence without
adopting
a
responsibility that's commensurate with
that set of ideas
i think that you either
orient yourself upward
you know to the star above the horizon
and try desperately to improve the
structure of being
or you work at counter purposes to it
and make things worse i don't think
there's a middle ground
and in fact to the degree there is a
middle ground it tilts towards the
negative because people who try to
occupy the middle ground
um
try to
generally try to accrue the benefit
let's say without
adopting any of the risk and that's not
acceptable
not helpful
so
that's a soul to me if you're having a
discussion with someone
and they're talking about things that
don't have those characteristics right
that they haven't made personal then the
conversation is almost never interesting
it's because the person is
it's just an they're just they really
are an empty shell through which
ideologue ideology cliches and slogans
are pouring there's nothing about that
that's compelling because
you don't see
the grappling
you don't see that the other person has
grappled with the ideas and come to
their own unique conclusions
and it really is in that mingling of the
abstract and the particular that
compelling wisdom is to be found
and so that's
that's
and then
concretely speaking well there's ways of
earning your knowledge and part of that
is
reformulating it in your own words
that's thinking it through right
and discussing it until you have it at
hand you can talk about it and you can
generalize from it because you truly
understand it but a huge part of that is
also putting it into practice and
deriving your own conclusions as a
consequence and some of that can be done
with debate it's like here's an idea i
came across and
here's the idea and here's what i think
it means
and this is
how i think it would change things if i
put it into practice this is how i
understand this idea and what do you
think of that
like that's a good
debate or discussion
you know because then the other person
can say well
i don't really agree with the way you
formulated that or i don't agree with
your conclusions and hopefully it's a
real discussion and not just
one-upmanship you know because that's a
pretty dull game i think that the best
approach to ameliorating inequalities to
strengthen the individual i mean that's
and that's what i've concentrated on
doing like we have this program
uh the self-authoring suite
and there's a component of that that
helps people write an autobiography and
another component that helps them write
an analysis of their personality and
another component that helps them write
out a plan for the future and we've used
that we've studied the effect of having
people write out a detailed plan for
their future and it's a proper plan it's
like okay look you you get to have what
you want three to five years down the
road you get to have the friends you
want you get to have the family you want
you get to have the career you want the
education you get you get to take care
of yourself properly you get to
withstand
the temptations of drug and alcohol
abuse and other sorts of impulsive
pleasures you get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time okay what
does that look like for you
write it out what does it look like just
you need a vision and then you need
another vision of how terrible things
could be if you let all your bad habits
get the upper hand and we've had people
do that in an experimental situation and
mostly they were college students and
the consequences of that there were two
consequences one was
general which was that university
students were about 30 percent more
likely to stay in university and got
grades that were about 25 percent better
which is a walloping effect but even
more interestingly and this is the
coolest thing i think that we ever
discovered us in our in in our
psychological research
we did this research in holland at the
um
at the erasmus university in rotterdam
at the rotterdam school of management
and we ran business students through the
future authoring program for multiple
years so several thousands of them and
we stratified them by gender and
ethnicity pretty a pretty rough cut men
and women and then
dutch nationals and non-western ethnic
minorities okay and so the the
performance was like this the dutch
women were at the top
then the dutch men
then
then the non-western ethnic minority
women then the non-western ethnic
minority men and they were behind the
dutch women by by by they they showed
about an 80
decrement in performance really quite
catastrophic two years after they did
the future authoring program they were
ahead of the dutch women
it just blew us away because it was and
it was a perfect indication of the fact
that you can use a psychological
intervention to ameliorate what looks
like a sociological problem
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book i would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these these
small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 have non-proportional payoffs that's
part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week
you need a plan for the day you need to
plan for the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome before you can be a painter
who can paint what's beyond mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and and
even to some degree whatever creativity
you have is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is their places of
guidance and and there are places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines right i mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of the that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it and so then
the question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction this is
nietzsche's commentary on the catholic
church he's a great admirer of the
catholic church despite the fact that he
was also a radical
critic
critic of christianity said the cat see
the thing about the catholic church is
that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline
and once that discipline was established
then the disciplined mind could explode
in every direction which is precisely
what happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that when you're a
teenager and a young adult you have to
sacrifice everything you could have been
as a child to be the one thing that
you're aiming at but then that opens up
and and the universities are part and
parcel of that process and you need the
guidance because
the
the the library is too large to wander
through it unaided
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome for even more incredible
jordan peterson motivation check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i read this this
piece of work by jung a long while back
and he it was a meditation on um the
injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated something like that and what
jung pointed out